mesdames messieurs bonsoir un homme est
libre ce soir et pourtant il demeure
inculpé de l'assassinât d'un petit
garçon de 4 ans et demi
le petit grégory villemin vous souvenez
de cette enquête tout à la fois pénible
et compliqué avec cette famille ses
parents accablés lors des obsèques de
l'enfant mais aussi cette rumeur qui
allaient bon train laissant peser les
soupes sion sont les membres de cette
famille justement
et puis enfin l'arrestation et
l'inculpation de celui qui était donc
apparemment tout à la fois le corbeau
est l'assassin bernard laroche le cousin
du père de grégory
ce jour ensuite les expertises suivies
de contre expertise les témoignages
donnés pu rétracter bref depuis
plusieurs semaines le dossier s'était
effritée et aujourd'hui le juge
d'instruction a décidé de la remise en
liberté de bernard laroche qui demeure
néanmoins inculpé bruno le bref bernard
laroche libéré après 91 jours
d'incarcération 91 jours d'un feuilleton
à rebondissements le 5 novembre il fait
figure d'assassins potentiels dans le
meurtre de son neveu le petit grégory
villemin
même si tout homme est présumé innocent
tant qu'il n'est pas condamné mais les
gendarmes vont l'arrêter sur son lieu de
travail aussi peu discrètement que
possible
il est inculpé et incarcéré par le juge
d'instruction jean michel lambert sur la
foi d'une expertise graphologique et du
témoignage de sa belle-soeur muriel mais
des irrégularités apparaissent dans la
procédure de désignation des experts en
écriture on n'est plus si sûr que la
roche on est bien l'auteur et puis
surtout muriel le principal témoin à
charge se rétracte bernard hinault 100
nouveaux frais il est innocent jamais
techno frère pourtant dès le début de l'
enquête les soupçons s'étaient tournés
vers la roche dix jours après la
découverte du corps du petit grégory
la roche et sa femme sont longuement
entendu par les gendarmes avant d'être
relâchés j'adore m'entraîner parce que
j'avais une écriture qui elle a sablé à
celle du corbeau son pyjama tout est pas
moi j'ai là quand ça sera à quai et ne
pas peut trouver sept mois aujourd'hui
la libération de la roche ne change rien
à son dossier il reste inculpé
pourtant son avocat estime que c'est le
premier pas vers sa disculpation total
chaque chose en son temps il est bien
évident que monsieur juge d'instruction
qui libère bernard laroche dans les
jours prochains
ou alors il n'y aurait plus aucune
logique sera amené à rentrer dans un non
lieu mais ça chaque chose en son temps
je suppose que monsieur d'instruction
toute logique attend le résultat des
expertises d'écriture alors et puis ce
soir l'avocat des parents de grégory m
garraud a demandé que la gendarmerie
soit dessaisie de l'enquêté au profit du
srpj de nancy